هذا ما يبدو عليه المسار البطيء لروسيا في
جنوب أوكرانيا وكأن
قوات كييف تقترب من حسن ،
المدينة الأولى التي استقبلها الكرملين
هنا ، حيث يتم إجلاء الكثير من الناس يومًا
بعد يوم والهدوء المخيف
على عكس هذه الآثار التي نراها في كل
مكان.  الحقول
مجرد وابل مستمر خلال الأيام الماضية
، الحافلة هي الطريقة الأخيرة للخروج من هنا
متجهة من الباب إلى ما تبقى من كل
باب ،
كانت قرية باساد
بيكروفسكي آخر موقع لأوكرانيا لأيام
، وهذا ما تركته روسيا
من الضوضاء  هل تسريب الغاز الرئيسي للقرية
بشراسة
حرب الإبادة التي قام بها بوتين ، تأكد من
عدم التغاضي عن هذه المدرسة
التي مزقها صاروخ من قبل ،
فمن الصعب تخيل الحياة تعود
هنا حتى عندما يتوقف القصف وهو
الآن لا
نركض
لتغطية  مشاة البحرية هنا
يتقدمون للأمام حيث يمكنهم
مطار هيرسون القريب جائزتهم الآن
لدينا طريق صغير إلى المطار
لقتل
اللعين دانيال جندي لبناني سابق
العمل في التلفزيون متزوجًا من أوكراني
قبل أسبوعين ، كان هذا المكان يعيش
فيه ولا
شيء ملأته الحافلة مع أي شخص متبقي
يريد ترك أي شخص يمكنه التنقل
بنفسه
، يُطلب منا اصطحاب أولئك الذين لا
يستطيعون والذين يتذكرون آخر مرة جاءت فيها الحرب
إلى أوروبا
بينما نترك القصف يضرب القرية
، فقد أصبحت فراش موت مليئة
بألغام ذخيرة مصنفة قال هذا الرجل إنه كان هناك نزاع
على الطريق الخارج من هناك على مدار أيام
بسبب وعاء خرساني محاط
بهذه العوالم الهادئة الصغيرة التي تمزق
هذا  كانت امرأة في بولندا عندما
أخذ الروس بلدتها ، ابنها حيث
أطفالها هم
نيكولاي لا يستطيع سماع الانفجار حقًا في
سنه ،
لكنه أرسل زوجته للعيش مع
ابنته في المدينة
التي أقامها لحماية كل
ما تركوه من
قصف.  الطريق إلى الخارج مرة
أخرى ونحن نتجاوز قذائف بوتين الأرض
قد احترقت بسعادة حيث
يفقد جيشه ببطء
أي أرض هنا حصل عليها بنادق أوكرانيا التي
تدفعهم للخلف
لكن موسكو تفرض  تكلفة
هذه الثكنات الممزقة إلى
أنقاض بسبب الضربات الصاروخية التي قتلت
العشرات من الجنود الأوكرانيين بعضهم
أثناء نومهم صباح يوم الجمعة في واحدة من
أسوأ الخسائر المعروفة في الحرب ،
تكافح وحدة الصدمات هذه مع
بعض 40
مصابًا لأصدقائه بالاسم
ليست كل الإصابات تشتمل على دماء
كان هذا الجندي في الفراش في الطابق الثالث
عندما وقع الانفجار ووجد
نفسه في الطابق الثاني وقد
تحطمت ساقيه وفقد وعيه في
تلك الليلة ، حيث أصابت قوة الكرملين الحادة
هدفًا آخر حول ميكوليف
موسكو قد تفقد الأرض هنا ولكن
يفعل كل ما في وسعه لسحق وخنق ما
لا يمكن أن يكون
نيك بايتون والش CNN باساد
كرافكا أوكرانيا